there is no idealistic future you know  where it's just gonna it's gonna all be  right and we're just gonna be happy you  know the tragedy is that we don't  recognize it until after the fact but  um  everything is it's so cyclical you know  everything that is good  um at any time we're in we're having a  good time a comfortable time life is  good you know  um we can be 100 guaranteed that it's  gonna get bad again yeah you know and as  bad as it is you can be 100 guaranteed  that it's going to get good again you  know and I guess the key is to not waste  that suffering when it comes like see it  as a  I see it as a gift see it as an as as an  opportunity to open our eyes and and to  be able to really recognize  recognize what is good and and be able  to really value it as it's happening